digamos que tenemos un objeto viajando
en forma circular y lo que dibuje aquí
son los vectores velocidad en diferentes
puntos de esta trayectoria tengo aquí mi
vector
de uno
aquí tengo mi vector velocidad 2 y aquí
tengo mi vector velocidad 3
y vamos a asumir que aunque la posición
de sus vectores es diferente la magnitud
de estos vectores es la misma y es
constante voy a llamar a la magnitud de
los vectores b van a darse cuenta que
esta es una cantidad de escalar porque
no tiene la flechita arriba esto es una
cantidad escalar no es un vector y esta
vez minúscula la voy a llamar rapidez
y esta rapidez va a ser igual a la
magnitud
de los vectores
de 1
y esto va a ser igual a la magnitud del
vector de 2
y esto a su vez será igual a la magnitud
del vector de 3
y vamos a asumir que este objeto está
viajando en una ruta circular
más o menos circular o imagínense que lo
que estoy dibujando es un círculo
con centro aquí y con un radio r ahora
lo que voy a hacer es dibujar los
vectores posición de cada uno de estos
puntos en el tiempo entonces tengo aquí
acá
mi vector posición que voy a llamar
nivel 2 posición acá
r2
y mi vector
posición
bueno entonces tenemos que la posición
va a ser diferente pero la magnitud de
estos vectores posiciones va a ser la
misma
voy a llamar r
a la magnitud de cada uno de estos
vectores de nuevo esta r es una escala
de su retorno tiene una flechita aquí y
está r es igual a la magnitud
de mi vector de posición
r 1 y esto es igual
el vector a la magnitud de mi vector r 2
y es igual a la magnitud de mi director
r3
lo que quiero hacer aquí es demostrarles
visualmente que dados en este radio y
esta rapidez la magnitud de la
aceleración centrípeta que llamaré hace
aceleración centrípeta va a ser igual a
esta velocidad o esta perdón a esta
rapidez al cuadrado entre
el radio del rector posición
/
vamos a llegar a esto pero ahorita vamos
a explicar visualmente de dónde sale
esta fórmula
bueno aquí tengo entonces mis vectores
velocidad voy a tomar cada uno de estos
vectores y lo voy a graficar de manera
diferente tengo aquí
mi vector 1
este
aproximadamente mi vector 2
y este
mi vector b3
cuál es el radio de este círculo qué
bueno si yo dibujara todo uno cada uno
de los vectores velocidad de mi objeto
pues tendríamos más o menos un círculo
también cuál sería el radio de este
círculo pues sería la magnitud de mi
vector velocidad que es como les comenté
una velocidad constante entonces yo
conozco que esta magnitud de director
velocidad pues es
esto que ya me esté escalar el radio
la rapidez ve
y conocemos cuál es esta magnitud
y bueno sabemos que el radio de este
otro círculo pues es la magnitud del
vector posición y qué es lo que ocasiona
el cambio de dirección en estos vectores
velocidad bueno va a ser el vector
aceleración que si lo graficó va a ser
aquí así aceleración 1
este va así más o menos
vector aceleración 2 y este
vector aceleración 3
y quiero que ustedes noten la analogía
que hay aquí
conforme el objeto da vueltas el vector
posición va a ir cambiando como las
manecillas del reloj y aquí fuera se
muestran los vectores velocidad en este
otro ejemplo tenemos aquí adentro los
vectores velocidad que se muestran como
las manecillas de un reloj que van
cambiando y aquí lo que está causando el
movimiento son los vectores de
aceleración
en este otro lado de los vectores
velocidad son tangenciales a la posición
y son perpendiculares al radio lo mismo
va a ocurrir en esta parte donde la
aceleración es perpendicular a los
vectores velocidad si trasladamos todos
estos vectores aceleración aquí en este
círculo los dibujamos estos van a ser
los vectores aceleración pues vamos a
ver que todos van a estar buscando el
centro se estar van a estar dirigiendo
hacia el centro por lo que todos estos
son vectores de aceleración centrípeta y
asumimos que todos esos vectores también
tienen la misma magnitud entonces tengo
mi cantidad de escalar aceleración
centrípeta como les digo no des vector
va a ser igual a la magnitud del vector
aceleración centrípeta 1 o bueno lo
pongo como los dibuje aquí
a uno a la magnitud de este vector que
es igual a la magnitud de la aceleración
2 que es igual a la magnitud del vector
aceleración 3
ahora lo que quiero pensar es que tanto
me lleva o me llevará para llegar desde
este punto hasta este otro punto a este
recorrido de esta pues esta ruta
circular
entonces bueno tengo una forma de
resolverlo
cuál es la longitud del arco que se
recorre en esta parte que es un cuarto
de circunferencia más o menos es un
cuarto de la circunferencia
bueno
esta parte desde circunferencia es igual
a 2 p
esta es la circunferencia total del
círculo por el radio r multiplicado por
entonces también quiero saber bueno esta
es la longitud de este arco longitud del
arco
quiero saber también qué tiempo va a
tardar en recorrer este este cuarto de
circunferencia y para saber el tiempo
pues tengo que dividir la longitud del
recorrido entre la rapidez o lo que es
lo mismo no voy a escribir por acá el
tiempo que es un escalar que me lleva a
recorrer esto va a ser igual a la
longitud del arco que ya puse aquí que
es 2 pi por el radio que es r
multiplicado por un cuarto porque es una
cuarta parte de la circunferencia entre
la rapidez y la rapidez es ver
recordamos esto no es velocidad es
rapidez es una escalar repites
y bueno aquí ya tengo el tiempo de
recorrido
y el tiempo que se tarda en recorrer
esta ruta pues va a ser exactamente el
mismo que voy a tomar para recorrer esta
parte de la circunferencia de este otro
círculo el de vectores de velocidad
bueno ahora el tiempo va a ser el mismo
pero ahora aquí la longitud base al
diferente cuál es la longitud de esta
otra ruta pues igual tiene que ser un
cuarto de la circunferencia pero ahora
con este radio velocidad
entonces tengo que en este lado mi
tiempo de recorrido va a ser igual a la
longitud que es 2 pi
ahora el radio es la velocidad por un
cuarto porque es un cuarto de la
circunferencia entonces ahora es
el cuarto de 2000 ahora no es r&b y la
rapidez
/ reír la magnitud de la aceleración
que es bueno digamos que la la velocidad
bueno la rapidez pero en este caso es
exactamente el correspondiente aquí
tenemos nuestros vectores velocidad que
es sobre lo que dividimos el tiempo y
aquí tenemos los tres vectores de
aceleración que sobre lo que vamos a
dividir aquí la longitud para obtener el
tiempo entre mis vectores bueno más bien
entre la magnitud de mi aceleración sean
típica
y estas dos cantidades son iguales este
tiempo va a ser el mismo entonces puedo
igualar ambos elementos de la ecuación
de manera que me queda dos pi y por
radio como del este radio
por un cuarto
entre la rapidez va a ser igual a igual
2 pin en este caso es el vector
velocidad por el cuarto
/ la aceleración zenttric puedo
simplificar estos términos puedo quitar
estos elementos de aquí y que me quede
el radio entre la aceleración es igual a
la radio entre la rapidez es igual a la
rapidez entre la aceleración siempre
pesa si yo quiero dejar solita la
aceleración científica
puedo pasarla multiplicando o
multiplicar ambos lados por este término
aceleración satisfecho centrípeta
multiplicado por el radio entre la
rapidez es igual a la rapidez
sigo simplificando es voy a multiplicar
todo por la rapidez entonces no va a
quedar la aceleración centrípeta por el
radio igual a la rapidez por la rapidez
la rapidez el cuadrado finalmente la
aceleración sentir pp es igual a mi
rapidez al cuadrado entre el radio que
esta es la misma fórmula la que
queríamos llegar desde el principio